last night we talked to the governor of
arkansas republican called asa
hutchinson he just vetoed a bill that
banned the chemical castration of
children in arkansas
we asked him why he did that he was
gracious enough to come on and explain
early on in our conversation though it
became clear that governor hutchinson
hadn't done a lot of research into the
topic
there are a lot of things he didn't seem
to know for example in february one of
the oldest medical journals in the world
the bmj
summarized researchers findings on
puberty blockers the chemicals at the
heart of this debate
here's what they found quote puberty
blockers used to treat children
aged 12 to 15 who have severe and
persistent gender dysphoria
had no significant effect on their
psychological function
thoughts of self-harm or body image
however as expected the children
experience reduced growth in height and
bone strength
so there's that keep in mind the
governor said children needed these
drugs
in order not to become clinically
depressed that study suggests the drugs
don't help
they only hurt children's bodies but
there are other studies for example one
conducted by london's tavistock clinic
that found that puberty blockers in fact
increased instances of self-harm and
suicidal ideation
in some children and those are the only
studies that have
found that just days ago britain's
national institute of health and care
excellence determined that there is
quote
very low evidence supporting the idea
that puberty blockers
should be given to minors the limited
research we do have suggests that
permanent life-altering treatments don't
make gender
dysphoria any better in fact those drugs
may
make it worse the most thorough
peer-reviewed study on the topic was
conducted in sweden
researchers followed the outcomes of
people who had undergone sex
reassignment surgery which the arkansas
bill
bans for minors 10 to 15 years after
they underwent sex reassignment surgery
the suicide rate for patients in sweden
had jumped by more than 2 000 percent
how's that a victory
it's not it's a tragedy we asked asa
hutchinson about any research he might
have read that contradicted these facts
he didn't point to any he clearly hadn't
read
any that contradicted those facts and
that led us to wonder
how exactly was asa hutchinson convinced
that vetoing this bill
was a good idea
you clearly aren't familiar with the
research and so my question is have you
spoken to any of the biggest employers
the big companies in arkansas about this
have you taken any calls
from tysons from dillard from walmart
has anyone from those companies called
you about this bill
no have you and i just want to be clear
on this have you spoken to
any corporate interest in the state of
arkansas about this bill
tucker i answered that i answered that
question and i said no i have not
asa hutchinson was quite definitive on
that and of course we had to take his
word for it he was very
emphatic no i haven't but it looks like
he was how to put this
lying the day that we spoke to asa
hutchinson in fact the walton family
endorsed his decision to veto the bill
that had just passed the arkansas
legislature
now the walton family is not just any
family it's the richest family in the
world and of course the most powerful
family in the state of arkansas
they control walmart and sam's club and
they wanted asa hutchinson to know that
he had done
exactly what they wanted him to do quote
we support governor asa hutchinson's
recent veto the walton family wrote
any policy that limits individual
opportunity also limits
our state's potential so if walmart's
going to sell a lifetime
supply of drugs to trans youth it would
be nice if asa hutchinson could
veto this legislation and any bills like
it
it's possible that hutchinson ignored
the wishes of the walton family and
trusted the experts that we couldn't
find any experts
who agreed with him what's interesting
is we spoke to someone today who knows
ace hutchinson very well who
says confirming our worst fear that yes
he very much would like a board seat
at walmart when he leaves just a few
days ago by the way ace hodginson
appeared on this network to admit that
before making any decisions on
transgender issues he first considers
what
we're quoting major global corporations
think
the home of some major global
corporations here in arkansas
they're certainly worried about the
image of our state but we're trying
to send the signal that you can protect
conscience
you can protect girls and sports
without being discriminatory and
trying to say we're not diverse and
tolerant
of different lifestyles and that's
important for us as a state
and what we have to achieve as a nation
oh we're the home of some major global
corporations governor hutchinson said
and they worry about the image of the
state they worry less about the children
of the state
who if asa hutchinson had had his way
could continue to be chemically
castrated
by quack doctors tells you a lot and
we'll be watching to see if ace
hutchinson
winds up on the board of walmart we
really will